[Music]
a top immunologist says he regrets
voting for joe biden after the president
announced strict new vaccine mandates
last week in a tweet he says quote i
voted for biden as a mccain republican
it was an error and i now regret it
thursday night's chess beating was one
of the most destructive and divisive
speeches ever given by a u.s president
who claims to be a well-reasoned uniter
acting on science joining us now to
explain is immunologist dr human nora
cosm
doctor what brought you to that point
morning brian thanks very much for
having me um look you know i was
reflecting this past weekend on on the
911 remembrance and i remember back in
2001
how essentially every uh media outlet
was united and transmitting the same
message you know we're in a position
where our country for the past several
years has been tremendously divided and
you know frankly as a friend to john
mccain you know i felt that president
biden
stands a chance of uniting the country
acting on science taking down the
temperature if you will and you know on
thursday i finally came to the
recognition as an immunologist based on
this the rigidity of this mandate
and and the massive blunder that's
contained within it uh that this is not
happening um you know i i have to say uh
the uh the mandate as as as it stands
um
essentially is has opened the door to
discrimination against about 80 to 100
million americans who are naturally
immune i mean these folks are
essentially being discriminated against
uh the president united states pointed
to them and and opened the door to a
massive level of discrimination and it's
not just you know verbal discrimination
we're talking about loss of employment i
can't tell you the number of emails i
receive every day
of americans who are naturally immune
and i know from a scientific perspective
and i know some of your guests in the
past have talked about this certainly dr
mackery has been on uh with tucker and
with with a variety of different uh
hosts
the natural immunity is as effective
if not more so than vaccine immunity so
the notion that the present united
states leaves the door open
to this level of discrimination against
a massive class of americans is just
totally unacceptable you know what i was
struck by
with your huge background i mean with
this rich background university of
pennsylvania um this is your area of
expertise but you say it's unscientific
it's illegal but you also say it's
unethical to give somebody a vaccine
when they have natural immunity and if
75 percent of the country has already
gotten one shot and you factor in the
natural immunity maybe there's something
else going on here doctor and maybe
people who aren't vaccinated aren't
villains as they've been made out to be
well they're look i i think i think
certainly there's there's there's a
place for immunity mandates right i mean
especially in places of public
engagement but but the reality is in the
midst of this outbreak there are about
100 million americans according to cdc
estimates who are already naturally
immune and these folks are for the most
part um
the vast majority of them are are
actually immune and and i think that the
notion that you know
if any particular subset of these folks
wants to you know avoid the vaccinations
at this time that they would be forced
at the risk of loss of employment or
educational opportunities i think it's
completely draconian you know it's nuts
frankly it goes and goes in the face of
medical necessity and and frankly i
think it's a constitutional violation i
mean uh right now we're in the process
of litigating a case out in michigan
against michigan state university uh the
plaintiff is gina norris and the new
civil liberties alliance is going to be
litigating this in federal court um the
idea is is this an actually an
unconstitutional thing when it comes to
um
the class of natural millions of
americans who are naturally immune i you
know i believe it's medically uh
ethically uh you know incorrect and
certainly uh it's very likely that it's
constitutionally uh a violation as well
and i can't tell you uh as someone
apolitical like you a doctor who is an
expert in the field saying it has so
much weight uh dr norcasm thanks so much
thanks for having me